بدوره تامر رئيس الاوكرانيه
القياده الروسيه بمحاوله استخدام عيد
الميلاد كغطاء لوقف تقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه شرقيه البلاد ووجهها لينسكي
خطابا الى الشعب الروسي باللغه الروسيه
قائلا انسحاب الجيش الروسي من كامل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هو الطريق هو الوحيد
لوقف الحرب ووقف خسائر الارواح
الروسي انني قدمت في وقت سابق صيغه
اوكرانيه للسلام اشترطت خروج القوات
الروسيه من جميع الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا
الشرط هو الضمان الوحيد لانهاء الحرب لقد
اقتربت خسائركم من 110 الاف
وهناك من قرر مواصله ارسال ابنائكم الى
الموت وهو يرفض صيغتنا لوقف العدوان
لانهاء الحرب يجب عليكم التحلي بالشجاعه
والتخلص من خوفكم من شخص واحد في الكرملين
ان هذا الخوف يدمر بلدكم قيادتكم تريد
استخدام عيد الميلاد كغطاء لايقاف تقدم
لقواتنا في اقليم دوم بس